this is a water jetpack but no that's
not me flying it this is me it's harder
than it looks okay but to understand how
it works we need to first talk rocket
science rocket science is meant to be
one of the most complicated things in
the world but the basic principle is
incredibly simple it's just Newton's
third law all forces come in pairs which
are equal and opposite to demonstrate
this I'm using a fire extinguisher on a
skateboard as the carbon dioxide is
forced at the back of the extinguisher
it puts a force forwards on me causing
me to accelerate
or that's the theory anyway
if you look closely you can spot the
exact moment I realize this is a fail so
what was the problem here well the force
applied to me by the carbon dioxide is
equal to the rate of mass ejected out
the back of the fire extinguisher call
it m dot for short multiplied by the
velocity of that exhaust gas so in this
case the carbon dioxide wasn't ejected
fast enough to create a big enough force
and overcome the small frictional forces
to get me to accelerate but it can be
done as has been demonstrated many times
on YouTube when the Space Shuttle lifts
off exhaust gases exit the nozzle at
three to four kilometers per second
ejecting an amount of mass of nine
thousand kilograms per second this
creates thrust equal to thirty million
Newton's or the equivalent of about two
million decent fire extinguishers now
imagine you're an astronaut preparing
for launch in the Space Shuttle you
would be seated not vertically but
horizontally perpendicular to the
acceleration that's because the human
body is a little bit like a water
balloon where the water represents your
blood and the balloon represents your
harder parts like your skeleton now if
you're accelerated up really quickly
then your skeleton accelerates up at
that rate but your blood tends to stay
where it is and this results in the
blood ending up in your feet now since
there's not enough oxygen going to your
brain you would black out but fighter
pilots face an arguably worse fate when
they accelerate down too fast because
then the blood all rushes to their head
and they suffer something called a
readout where the blood actually comes
out of their eyes nose mouth and ears
but back to astronauts since you're
reclined at worst the blood will end up
in the back of your body and the back of
your head but your brain will still have
enough oxygen to remain conscious now as
the spacecraft lifts off and start
speeding up the acceleration is
initially a very reasonable five to
eight meters per second squared that's
less acceleration than an object in
freefall here at the surface of Earth
but as the spacecraft continues to burn
fuel its mass decreases while the thrust
remains essentially constant now
Newton's second law says that the
acceleration of an object equals the net
force applied to it divided by its mass
so as the mass decreases the
acceleration increases and it increases
at an increasing rate so much so that at
the end of the rocket burn the thrust
has to actually be limited in order to
keep the acceleration from going over
three g's that's three times the
acceleration due to gravity or about 30
meters per second squared now the term
g-force has been invented to give a
sense of the amount of force experienced
by astronauts in multiples of the force
we experience every day right now you're
experiencing one g-force probably on
your butt if you're sitting down can you
feel that force but accelerating at 3
G's you would experience 3 g-forces
so the force between your back and the
chair would be the same as if you had
two of you stacked on top of you oh oh
they type down below huh oh you guys are
heavy oh man you know that feeling when
you're taking off in a plane and it
feels like you're pressed into the seat
well really it's the seat pressing into
you but if you imagine that feeling
times 20 that's what it would be like to
be taking off in the Space Shuttle now
an interesting little side note is that
we think of the space shuttles
acceleration as being mainly vertical
because that's what we see when it lifts
off but that's actually not true once
the Space Shuttle exits the thicker part
of the atmosphere it turns horizontal
and accelerates up to its orbital
velocity of 28,000 kilometers per hour
so most of the acceleration of a
spacecraft in orbit anyway is horizontal
so how is this like a jetpack well
unlike the shuttle you don't carry your
own propellant with you and also there's
no chemical reaction releasing energy
that drives the propellant down
instead the jetski pumps water out of
the lake and up that hose at a rate up
to 60 liters per second and then right
on these nozzles here the water changes
direction so it goes from coming up to
being fired at the bottom and that
change in momentum as it goes over the
bend is what actually pushes the jetpack
up because the jetpack is pushing down
on the water so by Newton's third law
the water has to push up on the jetpack
generating 1,800 newtons of thrust
that's roughly equivalent to a hundred
and fifty decent fire extinguishers this
could accelerate me at up to 1.5 G's and
you use your hands in order to steer
lifting up to drive yourself upwards
moving your hands down to accelerate
forwards and pretend like you're turning
a big wheel very gently in order to turn
side to side one thing you don't want to
do is try to explain the physics of the
jetpack while in the air that's what I
was trying to do here
while you're learning your thrust is
controlled by your instructor so if he
sees you doing something stupid he'll
just turn off the thrust and drop you
into the lake so you don't hurt yourself
that's generally a good idea unless
you're on a collision course with the
jetski I got a pretty fat lip from doing
this but luckily all my teeth were
intact when the thrust is equal to my
weight plus the weight of water in the
hose then I can hover or move with
constant velocity it's a common
misconception that you need a little bit
of unbalanced force to move with a
constant velocity in truth if the forces
are balanced you will just continue
moving with whatever constant velocity
you have the other common misconception
about Rockets is that you need something
to push off like the atmosphere in
reality what you're pushing off is the
propellant so even without the air
around a water jetpack would still work
because you're pushing off the water
that is coming out of those nozzles if
you want to go jetpacking I recommend
you go easy on the controls I mean the
worst thing you can do is overcompensate
which i think is a typical human
reaction because you're reacting to
where you are and how fast you're moving
then you're not reacting to acceleration
which is the real thing that you can
control so even if you're coming down
towards the water quite quickly you may
be slowing down so it may be okay and
you don't need to adjust anything you
just kind of need to trust that the
jetpack will get you out of any trouble
it's a pretty incredible experience
feeling the power that water rushing
past you it's the closest I've gotten to
flying really the power physics now many
of you may not know that I have a second
channel called to veritasium and I've
been posting more videos on there
recently so if you want to check them
out then click on this annotation or the
link in the description if you ever want
to download a veritasium video you can
do that now via iTunes by clicking this
link and that's a service provided to me
by science alert which is one of the
greatest Facebook pages on science that
exists so click on this link if you want
to check them out
alright thanks for watching